foreign
for the Wall Street Journal this is a
special episode of tech news briefing
part of our four-part series on the next
generation of climate Tech
imagine you're say a company that can't
cut your carbon emissions enough you
might try to at least offset them by
buying carbon credits but it can be hard
to track those credits or to know if the
projects they're tied to actually reduce
the amount of CO2 in the atmosphere
One Way some people think carbon credits
could be improved
stick them on a blockchain The Ledger
technology that underlies crypto but
existing players in the space like the
carbon credit registry Vera see problems
using this kind of system in May Vera
said it would stop letting credits on
its registry be turned into blockchain
tokens it's working on new rules for how
crypto could be used in this space
[Music]
so how does this all work anyway and
what are Vera's big concerns Dieter
Holger covers sustainable business for
wsj pro and he joins me now to break
things down hi Dieter thanks for joining
me hi thank you so how does this process
of turning a carbon credit into a token
work and apparently I need to know
something about retirement here right so
the retirement process means that
usually a company could be an individual
as well or another organization but
quite frequently a company that's trying
to make up for their emissions would you
know buy a bunch of credits and then
those credits would be retired when they
make a climate claim it's effectively
taken out of circulation so this process
opened a window for crypto enthusiasts
right they saw a means to use this
retirement process to take carbon credit
out of circulation from a traditional
carbon credit exchange like Vera and
then place it on the blockchain with a
token that has that receipt from that
retirement attached to it
okay so retiring essentially means the
credit has been used but when it's
turned into a token I guess that makes
it look like it's been used even though
it hasn't been claimed by say a business
or a government is that what the carbon
credit registry Vera has a problem with
can you explain a bit more about its
concerns essentially Vera was losing
control over the carbon credits they
verify and the claims buyers make with
those credits you're not supposed to be
retiring something unless you're
claiming a climate benefit right and so
that was probably the primary concern
and then the second concern which is
probably maybe equally valid is once
these tokens go on to these crypto
exchanges Vera doesn't know their
customer they want to know who is using
these tokens who is claiming the benefit
from them and that becomes essentially
impossible once they go into crypto land
why is that a problem if they don't know
who the client is well the whole goal of
carbon credit Registries like Vera right
is to support poor environmental
projects and direct money to these
projects and they want to make sure that
the people who are claiming these
benefits are doing these for the reasons
they should be which is to help the
environment right
the market for carbon credits is far
from the only one that's experimented
with blockchain tech over the last few
years though many are finding it's not
necessarily a silver bullet still there
are plenty of crypto enthusiasts who
think carbon credits have a legitimacy
problem and that blockchain can help
one of those people is Luisa dimei the
CEO of moss Earth a for-profit
blockchain company based in Sao Paulo
Brazil last year it raised 10 million
dollars from investors and back in
August 2020 Moss used a strategy of
retiring Vera credits that protected the
Amazon rainforest to create its own
token I spoke with Louis adame at the
end of last year to discuss all of this
hi Luis thanks for joining us hi Zoe
thank you so much for the invitation I
its basic level what's the point of
having Carbon offsets on the blockchain
okay a carbon credit is a digital
certificate that proves
that either a company or an
environmental project sequestered so
took CO2 out of the air or avoided the
emission of CO2 it has been a system
that has always been based on trust
meaning that the company acquired the
credit because it did some diligence on
the project and it believed that it was
trustworthy Etc but it never really knew
with 100 certainty whether the project
was selling them
a hundred thousand credits and
effectively it was only retiring or
canceling 50 000 and pocketing the fifty
thousand difference and when you put it
on blockchain you avoid that uncertainty
because you can tell the quantity you
can tell how much the project actually
canceled and retired you can tell the
origin you can tell all sorts of
information that the previous system
really didn't provide I mean
could also be kept in another digital
version it doesn't necessarily need a
decentralized ledger for it I disagree
with that point I think there is an
important advantage of decentralization
because you know one of the complaints
that people have about the global carbon
credit system
is that only a few registries
actually control most of the
transactions and now the power of
decentralization is or the issue that it
solves is that the Registries they wear
too many hats nowadays so they wear the
hat of like the system regulator so they
make sure that only
trustworthy players are there two they
establish what the protocols are on how
you know like a wind farm or a
conservation project in Brazil in the
Amazon forest how to calculate those
carbon credits so they're the ones who
establish those protocols so that they
are standardized and finally they
control the Registries which are nothing
more than
digital Notary offices like databases
the problem is that it's all based on
trust
there's no reason why that is not on
blockchain okay okay but if I can just
jump in here I mean let let's say we put
that on blockchain how do you still know
that those projects are legitimate you
still need somebody to go and check
whether or not they're burned you know
whether or not they're retiring some of
these credits are those credits actually
equivalent to one ton of carbon so there
are two issues in discussion here one is
the validation of the credits I'm not
saying those shouldn't be done by
Watchdogs and Global Registries that's
their job to have Auditors prepare
reports and visit the projects and make
sure that they're following the
protocols and that they're legitimate
right once that's established I'm saying
that from that point onwards when you
know the project is selling to an
intermediator that is selling to a
company
that whole flow needs to be on
blockchain it cannot be off chain
because we just have the technology
nowadays which is blockchain to make
sure that there's no double counting
there there's no double spanning and
that those can be traced back to the
project so it's not you know a Panacea
like an all-encompassing solution but it
does solve for that transaction after
the credits have been issued and have
been deemed solid
switch to some more recent news we were
talking about rules for the carbon
credit industry Vera the largest carbon
offset registry said it was changing its
rules to prevent crypto from effectively
being used in carbon credit Registries
how has that impacted your business well
first it's important to highlight that
it was a suspension not a full-time
prohibition it has impacted our business
in the sense that we lost as a company
we lost one of our sales Channel
because we sold on crypto exchanges or
on token format to some funds and
companies and now we're just selling
straight
non-tokenized carbon credits so in a way
it's a bit of
an unfortunate setback I think for the
world in that we were advancing on the
use of blockchain for this and then now
we're back to step one I just want to
make sure I'm understanding this right
at the moment the carbon credits that
you're selling are not on blockchain are
not on blockchain correct all right
Louis adame from Moss thank you so much
for joining us for this conversation
thank you for the very great questions
and for the time zone
we reached out to Vera for a comment a
spokesperson said the registry will have
an announcement on tokenized carbon
credits soon
now to understand more about the bigger
picture challenges facing the carbon
credit market and whether blockchain
Tech can really make a difference I want
to bring back wsj Pro sustainable
business reporter Dieter Holger Dieter
the CEO of moss split the problems of
carbon credits into two buckets first
there's this issue of whether a credit
is really tied to a legitimate project
and second that each credit can be
duplicated so that they aren't double
counted and he told us that blockchain
addresses this second issue but Dieter
which is the bigger problem I mean the
issue of double counting has long been
discussed right this is the problem of
potentially two companies both claiming
the benefit from a carbon credit the
blockchain claims that it can provide a
more transparent Ledger right a more
publicly accessible transparent ledger
so it is certainly a solution solution
to this problem but the issue of quality
is probably grabbing a lot more
attention right now because sure these
credits could be counted twice but we
mainly want to make sure these credits
are at least in the eyes of critics
would say that these credits are
actually doing something positive for
the environment right that they're
actually doing what they advertise or
accomplishing what they set out to do
that's a problem that's going to have to
be addressed by standard Setters and
regulations you know when people think
about blockchain when they think about
the crypto industry they often think
about how energy energy intensive it can
be so what have experts said about how
that energy intensive blockchain fits
into an area where it's trying to reduce
the amount of carbon in the world right
so the cryptocurrency industry is well
aware of the energy intensive problems
that they are facing right we have seen
some of the early use cases of these
crypto carbon tokens coming from actual
other exchanges or crypto platforms so
they will buy crypto carbon tokens and
then they will what they call burn them
so they can claim them against their own
emissions so people in the crypto world
at least are using crypto carbon tokens
today to try to alleviate some of those
energy concerns that we're seeing so
sort of this circular world of
blockchain carbon credits supporting the
blockchain carbon credit Market that's
exactly right I mean it makes a lot of
sense when you think about it that the
early adopters of crypto carbon tokens
would of course be other crypto
platforms or people who are enthusiastic
about crypto so that's where we're
seeing a lot of the use when it comes to
the claiming the environmental benefit
of one of these crypto carbon tokens all
right that was our reporter Dieter
Holger Dieter thanks so much for joining
us thank you
all right that's it for this episode of
tech news briefing be sure to check out
the other episodes of our special series
on new climate Tech and for more Tech
news head over to our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]